hey everybody this is international
master david pruss for chess.com and
today i'm going to show you one single
endgame idea
that is of staggering beauty as well as
purity and simplicity
and i'm calling it the reti idea after
richard retty
who composed the position that you see
before you as an end game study
but of course richard retti
had a million amazing chess ideas so
there are actually a lot of ideas that
perhaps deserve to be called the reti
idea
this idea is basically an advanced yet
not hard to understand
look at how the king actually moves in
chess and what his true potential and
speed is because a lot of people think
that a king moves
one space per move
but it turns out that diagonal and
straight
are two different distances right as
some of you know diagonal is root two
over two as far as straight
and in fact on the chess board as well
you'll see that there's a different
geometry to the king moving diagonally
so first look at this position and
consider white's quandary it's white to
play the white pawn is headed this way
to queen and the black pawn is headed
this way to queen
if you first think about this position
consider the white king in relation to
the black pawn does he have any chance
of catching that pawn before it queens
evidently not right
there's no way he's going to chase down
this pawn in fact he's two steps behind
him
okay okay second issue
you've got this pawn which could
potentially queen except the black king
seems to be on him can your king get to
this pond before the black king gets him
well let's see
not even close right
so
white seems to have lost the game and
retty published this and white to play
and draw and it must have stunned many
people however white does have a way to
draw
he has to move his king to its full
capacity and that means diagonally so he
plays king g7 heading one step towards
this pawn and one step towards this pawn
so black is going to
move his king towards the white pawn
and white is going to play king to f6
now white's threatening to catch the
black pawn so the black pawn runs
and now white will play king to e5
now the white king is getting close to
his own pawn very very close on the next
move he could defend it if black
captures this pawn though
king f4 and the white king has captured
the black pawn by reaching this little
box
so let's say black keeps moving his pawn
now the white king goes to defend his
pawn
black goes to queen and white goes to
queen and black can no longer prevent
white from also getting a queen and so
this end game will be a draw
of queen against queen
let's go all the way back to the
beginning
let's say instead of playing king to b6
the black pawn just runs right away now
white will play king 2 f6
continuing to always travel one step
towards his pawn and one step after the
black pawn
if the pawn continues to run
then after king 2 e6 the white king is
now close enough to his pawn to save it
and the game ends in a draw like this
white will get a queen
or black could now play king to b6
getting an eye on this pawn but then
after white plays king to e5 he's got
the dual thread of king d6 and king f4
like we saw before
right so the king moves diagonally makes
a double threat diagonally and gets a
draw and this by the way is also a
double attack
right which as i've said in another
video about chess tactics the double
attack is the fundamental tactic in
chess is to make two threats at once and
that's what this king is doing with his
fancy fast diagonal movements
now let's see one more example of this
same idea
okay so this position is again white to
play and draw and again it looks like
it'd be hard for the white king to catch
up with this black pawn remember it'll
be able to move two steps on its first
move so king to e8 h5
king f7 h4
looks at first highly hopeless right
secondly the black king seems to be
placed very nicely to keep the white
king from moving to his full potential
by controlling these three squares
and he seems to be in range of the white
pawn
so if white advances the pawn it looks
like the black king
will catch
him
right and now you can run this way but
you're still not going to capture this
pawn
you're closer
but no cigar
you actually have to stop him from
queening for it to count
so
how should white play
to save
this end game well there's one way to do
it
white starts with king 2 c8
moving apparently towards his pawn
to help it out and in fact if black
plays h5 now
white can queen his pawn because
in this position his king is stopping
the black king from catching the pawn
so after
king c8 the black king will step over
to keep an eye on this pawn
now how should white continue
this move would be an error the black
king catches the pawn and you still
can't catch
this pawn
so white plays king to b8
now he's again threatening on h5 to play
a6 a7 a8 escorted by his king
so the black king moves back to b5
to keep the pawn under wraps that's the
only way to keep this pawn captured
and now white plays
kind of like the ready idea king to b7
which is a step towards his pawn and a
step
towards that pawn
so black has to capture the pawn white
plays king c6 h5
king d5 the pawn can run as fast as it
wants but the king can run just as fast
as it
and again white has achieved a
miraculous
draw just arriving in time with his king
so there's a second example of
interesting ways
of this interesting way of using your
king
i hope you enjoyed this video and i'll
see you around on chess.com